all right dope tech one of my favorite
series it's the most fun because we get
to bring together a bunch of different
things that all have something in common
a bit of a theme if you will and the
theme for this one is a little bit
different all the items we're gonna do
in this video uh I had Rock Bottom super
low expectations for it that's just the
way it was and they all managed to
exceed those expectations in some way it
doesn't mean they're good products in
fact I don't even recommend buying any
of the things that we talk about in this
video but they all did manage to clear
that ultra low hurdle you'll see what I
mean so okay the first one is a family
friendly household robot
it's right here Astro say hi
to the thanks yeah okay so this is
Amazon's Astro and it's a it's it's a
robot you'll you'll see what I'm talking
about so you might have seen the
commercial they put on YouTube for
showing it rolling around and being
helpful to people bringing people drinks
things like that but you might have also
like me seen the headlines about it
basically that it's an unmitigated
disaster and it throws itself down
flights of stairs I honestly don't think
I would ever buy an astrobot from my own
home it's basically an Alexa speaker on
Wheels with a 10 inch screen and then
with a camera and a microphone to act as
a security camera
yeah my expectations are down here but
the funny thing is we got it I'll unmute
it we got Astro and we started using it
and it turned out that there were a
couple things that were impressive about
it three to be specific the first one is
just how impressively confident it is at
maneuvering around so Astro has a huge
wheel on either side that lets it go
over bumps and cables and move around
dramatically better than any Roomba or
robot vacuum and it's really good I mean
you just watch it cut around corners and
cut close to objects it never really
hits them but it seems to run routes
wherever it thinks it should be going
really well it moves around new objects
that were put in place after it mapped
your space and it just kind of rolls
around confidently honestly at this
point I kind of wish it had a vacuum
cleaner attachment or something because
it feels like this could be miles more
productive than any of the actual robot
vacuums but it is also notoriously bad
with glass walls and weird architectural
features it actually comes with a set of
stickers to put on any glass wall so it
knows that the wall is there and it
doesn't smash its face into them also we
don't have any stairs in here
so
yeah anyway the second thing is
literally just the set of speakers in
Astro so if you ask it to play music or
watch a video or something and you get
through the setup process and connect
your Amazon music account it's kind of
like a mini boom box on Wheels which is
kind of a unique product by itself I
guess so you can ask it to play videos
like an Echo Show it'll also try to play
videos on its 10 inch screen so you can
watch like a YouTube video with great
sound but the video will be at ankle
height so there's that it also randomly
likes to remind you that it can act like
a bird or a whale and then it'll
actually do it loudly but the last thing
just has to do with the screen they put
on this thing where the face is now it's
not that it's a particularly bright or
high resolution or high refresh rate
screen no it's got a five megapixel
camera on it that's not amazing you know
it's designed to just quickly look
around and recognize people but it also
gets that wrong all the time too so
what's impressive about the screen well
it sort of acts like a like a face like
a human like
character all the time it looks at you
it has these Expressions it's muted
right now so it looks like it's asleep I
hit the unmute button and it wakes up
and it makes these expressions and
noises and then when I call its name
from wherever I am in the room it could
just be hanging out somewhere it's
shockingly good at triangulating where
the voice came from and pointing the
face at it which doesn't sound that
impressive but when you think about it
it's kind of amazing look at it
hey Astro
how did it it's so good at that hey
Astra
I mean honestly this isn't particularly
useful at all I mean all it's doing is
pointing the screen at me but it's just
something weird about the way it looks
at you and it looks right at you every
time and it gives you some facial
expression every time it's also
typically A Blank Stare so like if you
give it a command it doesn't understand
it just looks at you it doesn't show any
error messages if you say a command and
it doesn't know what you're talking
about it just doesn't do anything it
just looks at you there's also sometimes
when I'm walking by it and I haven't
been in that room in a while and it sort
of perks up and looks at you and like
winks and makes a noise and says it
misses you which is
it's a thing that it does sometimes but
I just couldn't get over how good the
triangulation of like looking at the
voice was
super good that's dope Tech but you know
there's a laundry list of reasons I
would not actually buy this robot from
all the setup bugs and non-responses to
the terrible facial recognition
mistaking me for other people in the
studio to the shin height video calls
now there is a telescoping camera at the
top which will pop out and let you take
a higher quality selfie or check to see
if the stove is on or if something's on
the counter and you can remote control
it if you're away from the house but the
max height is 42 inches which is still
like below hip height and there's this
tough laggy steering and turning process
this is not very intuitive or fun at all
and then the last fun part that you
probably saw in the ad is it would like
bring drinks to people so I could send
it to another room and it would grab a
drink for me but that of course requires
someone being in the other room and then
putting a drink in the back and then
being sent back to where the person
initially called it from and so it's
just kind of like you might as well just
have someone bring you a drink in the
first place and all that's not even
considering the slightly on
uncomfortable reality of having an
Amazon camera and microphone follow you
around your house all the time
so but it is kind of cool add some stuff
four out of ten all right so this
looks like a normal Smart Watch Right a
little thick maybe but overall a pretty
classic design this is called the Huawei
watch buds why is it called the watch
buds you ask
well okay so I have a theory about two
in one devices that basically anytime
you combine two product categories into
one product it has to be worse at
something at one of those things like
when you get those two in one folding
laptop tablet hybrid things it's kind of
a worse laptop because now it has to be
thinner to be able to fold all the way
around but it's also a worse tablet
because the keyboard is still on the
back when you fold it and it's kind of
awkward so anyway this is a hybrid watch
and earbuds
watch buds so now my expectation with
this thing is that according to my
theory it's either going to be worse
earbuds or a worse smart watch or both
but let me just take a minute to admire
the fact that they actually pulled this
off and made it a real product in the
first place so this thing is it's by
Huawei it's real it's around 550 bucks
and Huawei knows how to make a good
Smart Watch so this is a pretty premium
large sized watch steel leather strap it
is kind of heavy but it doesn't look too
ridiculous on your wrist just like a
normal thick premium Smart Watch until
you hit that knurled button right there
at the bottom and it opens up and
reveals your earbuds each one is
automatically paired to your phone so
the second you grab one office magnetic
lid it takes over your audio from your
phone so okay real world situation
you're getting a phone call but you're
about to go drive somewhere walk around
so you want to be hands-free so you just
pop this open put one earbud in and
you're connected to your phone and on
the call
already so yeah these these earbuds are
truly mini they look tiny in my hands
actually tiny in anybody's hands and
then there's a clever bit of software
trickery so these two buds here are
actually basically identical there's no
right and left instead they have a
magnetic strip all the way around so you
can just slap them back in the lid in
whatever order you want and close it not
really think about orientation and then
when you take them out and put them in
your ears apparently all it takes is one
two nod gesture and already it knows
which one is the right ear which one is
the left ear and then calibrates your
stereo signal accordingly
that's pretty cool so okay for the two
in one question at the beginning
according to my theory these are either
a bad set of earbuds
or a bad smart watch or both so which is
it
well it's mostly bad earbuds like
impressively enough if you're into like
Huawei smart watches before you already
know some of the watch GTs have like a
week of battery life this watch
connected to your phone and acting like
a normal Smartwatch can still get three
days of battery life which in Smart
Watch world is actually still quite fine
like the display is still large and
bright and it just nothing about it
really feels compromised other than the
fact that maybe it's a little bit heavy
but I think if you gave this to like 9
out of 10 people they would never
suspect that there's earbuds inside but
the earbuds themselves that's where they
kind of feel much less premium like they
have active noise cancellation that
barely works but like who cares this is
much more of a convenience play this is
not for amazing sound quality this is
for the like I'm about to get on a phone
call right now and I don't want to have
to Fumble around and find my earbuds
they're just always on my wrist at all
times they have a three hour max battery
life with active noise cancellation on
fine but if I was going to listen to
something or do some audio activity for
more more than three hours
I'd probably have a comfortable pair of
headphones to do that with so this is
just like pure convenience jump on the
phone call you'll never lose your
earbuds or I mean I guess you could just
lose your whole watch
in which case you lost your earbuds too
I don't know I thought it was a cool
idea seven out of ten all right so this
last item is called it's called the
world's fastest shoes
so I've seen a lot of uh Last Mile
Transportation fads in my day from
Segways to scooters to hoverboards
boosted boards this problem has been
solved many times so when I started
seeing these things pop up my
expectations were very
very low but basically the explanation
is these are basically robotic motorized
rollerblades there's eight rollerblades
on the bottom of each one put your foot
in and you strap your foot in with your
shoe still on
that's how these work and the idea is
you just keep walking like a normal
person with your normal stride and
because of the motors and the wheels
it'll accelerate the way you walk by up
to 250 percent so for those wondering
they're claiming it'll have a maximum
speed once you get going of about five
to seven miles an hour but then I saw
the sites demo videos and I saw Casey
neistat's video you've probably seen
that they're called the shift Moonwalker
shoes you're supposed to just be able to
walk naturally and then the motors and
the wheels kick in and it's a natural
acceleration and you just start to
magically cover more ground than you
normally would if you were just walking
so I had to try them basically okay they
work as advertised meaning that you have
to try to walk like normal and really
heel toe it and after a few steps you
start to hear the motors kick in and it
almost feels like a controlled
rollerblading experience controlled
meaning you don't just go as fast as if
you were free rollerblading but you are
more stable because you're wearing your
normal shoes and then you're strapped
into these platforms and these things
are heavy as hell so there is a bit of a
learning curve and you just start to
walk around and you definitely feel
ridiculous when you first learn them and
you start to accelerate more and more
quickly turning is really hard because
you can't really turn while that foot is
down all eight wheels are on the ground
so you can only turn with the foot
that's in the air before it lands all of
this you you can get used to over time
so there's a learning curve but what you
don't really get from the videos on the
site is just how heavy these things are
and how loud they are as you're walking
they're like Clump Clump like walking
around and the whirring of the motors at
the same time you can hear someone
coming from a long way away from these
so as I'm using them I start to think
about the question which is would you
prefer this over a hoverboard or over an
electric skateboard or something or just
actual rollerblades and so the pitch is
that the advantage of these is that you
can walk with the normal energy of
walking and it just sort of effortlessly
Glides you along at a faster speed kind
of like one of those runways at the
airport but it's kind of not exactly
true because of how heavy they are and
the extra energy needed to pick up your
feet but if you get up to the top speed
I will say the amount of energy you're
spending is less than trying to jog at
that speed but the entire time I
couldn't get out of my mind one of these
things which had its day the hoverboard
is going to be a faster top speed and
less energy than walking and if you want
to go like up or down stairs or
something you just get off and just
carry it or one of these an electric
skateboard something like a boosted
board has a higher top speed than both
of these and is also less energy than
walking and also you would have to just
get off and carry it up the stairs so
the advantage of these would be that you
get to keep them on more often and that
it feels more natural because of the
walking motion theoretically though you
could leave these on as you go up and
down stairs if you're feeling really
bold I'll leave you with this though
they do charge via USB type c so there's
a plug in the back of each of them and
they last five to seven miles of range
on One battery charge they are water
resistant and they cost 1 400 dollars
so
5 out of 10. anyway I'm glad I got to
testing because I was really curious
what they would feel like
let me know what you think I should test
next on dope Tech thanks for watching
catch in the next one
[Music]